besides your sense he never actually
taught me all my argue though I searched
our other teachers because I didn't
quite get it you know what he was saying
I didn't quite get it I could see he
could do it I could see he was very
powerful he had a soft power it was it
like you could squeeze forever and never
fit his bone and it was very strange but
he never hurt me and yet he did hurt me
through the share power that he could
throw you know rather do we saved that
much power you sort of you get up
disorientated and you'd be this way he'd
be there after the throne
so um so my advice is all every the
answer doesn't sit with any of you
ask or look
at other teachers
tonight I'm going to talk about
um
I just lose the distance so right
against right
and one of my future say and the other
guy
at all your different Learners you must
grasp different things but as I make
this circle this hand stays quite High
so I need this the important thing is
this thumb
to get into there they can't get in
there if I turn it over
and grip it
so what ends up if the timing's right
wrong we end up sort of with a bit of a
hold and then we wonder why they can
block us
at the higher levels you know the
journey levels
well it's not this foot is turning as if
I'm some kind of mechanized machine
but that's down with what we want to
look for and then this hand is going to
attract your own thumb
then you don't exist and to be so
tightly gripping his wrist you do grip
it but you don't need it tightly because
you're off you've trapped your own thumb
s up and it took me about 20 years to
understand
it's the coordination bit
because men are physically strong
it could manifestly strong you know you
can sort of like get away with it like
this thing I'm doing it physically now
but there's a block there that's why
what I do is I'll lie on my body now and
I'll make you cry
and that's a bit like what I'm saying to
you about that you know listen to ask
for a question I'm not happy with that
answer I better not say anything because
these are whatever man
so I have to adjust to get under loans
if I do it correctly I'm in first then
here look I didn't have to adjust to
that I did began and
I went under him I was cheating because
I couldn't do the dirt bike
so if I use strength my thumb's in there
a bit but it's not what up to the the
clothes but if you see it's not up to
that bit
that's in there but it has no value now
so about nearly blocked I now lower my
body and I go under it
I'm not correct
foreign